oui
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pourquoi at il fallu un an
et demi pour que l'hypothèse d'un
accident de laboratoire à l'origine du
comique 19 et soudain droit de cité dans
les médias alors qu'il était encore il
ya peu rejeter d'emblée assimilée à une
théorie de la conspiration
qu'est ce qui a fait changer d'avis les
journalistes et les scientifiques qui
trouvait jusque là la thèse du pangolin
bien préférable alors pour un bep battre
nous avons un vide et nous avons invité
brice perrier vous êtes journaliste vous
êtes l'auteur de sart skov de aux
origines du mal chez belin la première
véritable enquête sur les origines de la
pandémie ou vous raconter comment
l'hypothèse d'un accident de laboratoire
a été écartée d'emblée par une bonne
partie du monde scientifique et la quasi
totalité des médias c'est seulement
depuis quelques semaines qu'il est
possible de l'évoquer alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui et pas hier à votre avis une
question parce qu'on n'avait pas
regarder ça de façon un peu objective je
vais dire au départ elle a été écartée
par notamment par deux papiers de
référence de hollande 7 qui considérait
cette hypothèse comme une théorie du
complot et un autre dans nature qui
estimait que ça ne pouvait pas être un
virus travail en laboratoire et donc
c'est devenu deux dogmes qui ont été
largement suivie au niveau mondial
olivier berruyer vous êtes le fondateur
d'un célèbre site de déconstruction des
propagandes de tous bords qui s'appelle
les crises et vous êtes l'auteur du
livre les faits sont têtus qui est paru
aux arènes depuis le début de la
pandémie vous avez été parmi les
premiers à parler de la gravité de
l'épidémie a réclamé des mesures fortes
vous êtes montré très critique vis-à-vis
du gouvernement des médias mais aussi
didier rahout et des complotistes qui
pensent que le virus n'existe pas ou
qu'il s'agit d'une gigantesque
manipulation orchestrée par will bill
gates alors quid de l'hypothèse de
l'accident de laboratoire dans quelle
catégorie le rangez vous vous savez en
fait il n'a pas une il y en a plusieurs
ce qui d'ailleurs explique un des
problèmes de compréhension qu'il y
assure ce sur ces hypothèses
l'hypothèse raisonnable je dirais
d'accidents de laboratoire a été comme
vous le disiez tout à fait écartée dès
le début de façon assez scandaleuse par
les médias au prétexte et parce que
c'est vraiment une théorie complotiste
mais il ya des théories complotistes qui
parfois s'avère vrai donc tu réduis
avoir une enquête
aujourd'hui un an après beaucoup des
grands scientifiques grand virologues
estime que c'est hautement improbable
mais il n'y a aucune certitude
et peut-être que dans quelques mois si
l'épreuve apparaissent en changera
d'avis anne cécile robert vous êtes
journaliste professeur associé à
l'université paris 8 vous êtes l'auteur
deux dernières nouvelles du mensonge aux
éditions lux dont vous êtes venu parler
dans cette émission a sorti il ya trois
mois et dans lequel vous expliquer que
l'on ne peut pas comprendre le
conspirationnisme il s'est installé dans
nos démocraties si l'on analyse pas
d'abord les vérités officielles qui ont
envahi la parole politique dans les
années 80-90 alors sur les origines du
virus de quel côté il faut t'il pencher
d'après-vous vérités officielles ou
théorie du complot
ce que je trouve intéressant déjà c'est
que cette hypothèse soit possible et si
on ne veut pas passer d'un virus à un
autre en se posant toujours les mêmes
questions
il est nécessaire d'interroger les
fonctionnement de l'économie mondiale
les rapports de force mondiaux qui font
que les laboratoires les puissances sont
dans des logiques de concurrence qui
favorise l'erreur par la précipitation
par par l'appât du gain et 7 et c'est
aussi intéressant de ce1 de nous
interroger sur la manière dont les
médias observe tout ça puisque depuis le
début de la pandémie
le traitement médiatique est souvent un
traitement au plus près d'eux du dernier
événement est pas à une analyse de long
terme des structures et des mécanismes
comme ac durant vous êtes le directeur
de l'essec l'association pour la science
et la transmission de l'esprit critique
vous co animer la tronche-en-biais une
chaîne youtube comptant deux cent
vingt-huit mille abonnés et cumulant 23
millions 622 1000 vu consacrer à
l'esprit critique et vous êtes l'auteur
de la science des balises
qui vient de paraître chez humaines
sciences elle qu'est un livre dans
lequel vous ne vous prononcez pas sur
les origines du commises pourquoi parce
que c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut des
années pour répondre à une question
complexe et qu'il ya des gens qui
adorent avoir les réponses avant les
autres ça me paraît pas prudent donc moi
je milite pour le scepticisme
scientifique pour la prudence avis
technique et j'ai pas la réponse
en fait donc il faut écouter les gens et
il ya des experts qui parle il me semble
que pour l'instant il estime qu'à une
une hypothèse naturel entre guillemets
est la plus probable
il faut attendre d'abord il un consensus
doit apparaître et être serein
alors ouais ya eu d'autres il peut-être
que je voudrais vous soumettre c'est que
il ya très peu de temps on a vu un
revirement de facebook qui jusqu'à
présent considéré l'hypothèse de
l'accident de laboratoire comme une
théorie du complot et à ce titre on
pouvait la chasse et du réseau social et
puis qui tout à coup annoncé que non
désormais on allait plus la chasse et du
coup de réseau social donc ça devenait
une théorie admissibles et au même
moment il ya joe biden qui a demandé aux
services de renseignement brettés
américain il leur a donné trois mois
pour trouver une explication plausible
aux origines du virus
si ç'avait été de telles preuves pour
n'aurait crié au scandale
est-ce que ça ça fait pas partie aussi
du revirement général
des médias toutacoo qui font que la
théorie du complot tout à coup pourrait
peut-être devenir la vérité officielle
de demain et il vaut mieux s'y rallier
bah c'est surtout le fruit de travaux
qui ont été faits par des chercheurs
contre le qualifié de marginaux qui qui
toute l'année dernière ont relevé
beaucoup de choses ont vu bien des
erreurs qu'ils étaient des papiers qui
ces autorités et qui en fait ne devait
pas qu'ils ont trouvé beaucoup de choses
notamment sur les travaux que faisait le
laboratoire de one sur une mine où on
avait trouvé le virus le plus proche sur
le fait qu'ils avaient effacé leurs
bases de données
peu de temps avant le début d'épidémie
et ces gens qui ont été ignorées écarté
pendant pendant un an
eh bien il se trouve que ils ont été
aussi après il ya des chercheurs
français notamment etienne decroly qui
préface mon livre qui lui s'est posée
aussi des questions et finalement ils se
sont rassemblés avec des chercheurs de
marseille des chercheurs de paris et des
gens aussi dessous notamment ce groupe
drastique qui avez vous trouvé beaucoup
de choses et ils ont fait une lettre
ouverte qui est paru juste après la
mission de de l'om est sawan et pour
dire qu'il fallait une véritable enquête
c'est vraiment et des chercheurs
internationaux il n'y a pas de défense
des chercheurs internationaux ça ça a
été le déclic ça a été vraiment la chose
qui a fait assez en fait ce travail que
ses drastiques et d'autres chercheurs
qui avaient été marginalisés parce qu'il
y avait dans les revues scientifiques
refusait les publications il y avait des
publications qui était contestable elle
ne pouvait pas être contestés dans les
revues et grâce en fait c'est certain
qu'ils sont fédérées un petit en partant
de marseille et qui ont réussi à faire
une lettre ouverte qui a eu un impact
mondial parce qu'elle est parue dans le
monde dans le wall street journal a été
repris par tous et ça ça c'était le
début d'un changement général qui après
s'est perpétuée avec la sortie du
rapport qui a été très décevant que on a
vu que c'était la mission de la mission
douanes qui en fait était
un rapport chinois on pourrait dire
parce qu'il y avait les midis les
envoyés de l' oms mais il y avait aussi
des experts chinois et fallait qu'ils
soient en accord donc ça dépend des un
peu du bon-vouloir chinois et à ce
rapport qui estimait que la thèse du
laboratoire était extrêmement improbable
et ne devait pas être encore recherché
et il a été désavoué le jour même de sa
parution par le patron de l' oms qui a
dit non c'est pas possible parce que y
avait cette pression depuis cette lettre
ouverte est vers les états unis d'autres
pays qui avait fait aussi de stress de
lettre pour demander une nouvelle
enquête est donc ça a été le début d'un
changement vraiment à haut niveau et qui
s'est encore concrétisé
ben il ya le mois dernier par une lettre
de scientifiques la de vraiment de très
haut niveau dans sa haine ce qu'il
disait en gros la même chose que les
autres et qui disait il faut faire il
faut faire une enquête et là là c'est
devenu mainstream on va bien olivier
berruyer vous y croyez vous le fait que
quelques dizaines de scientifiques
écrivant une lettre à l'om c'est l oms
pardon ça suffit à faire tourner casaque
aux médias et qui tout à coup encourage
aujourd'hui ce qui le condamné hier à
dix on fait actuellement c'est vrai tout
ça existait en effet les des chercheurs
ont fait des travaux assez intéressant
mais sans apporter de preuves dur il ya
une possibilité il ya des éléments en
effet qu'ils sont très étonnant pour que
cette épidémie départ allemagne alors
que c'est un des f1 cr des trois centres
mondiaux de recherche et
d'expérimentation sans doute un peu
dangereux sur les corners virus donc on
peut se poser la question mais non enfin
personnellement dans une analyse et
propagande je dirais pas que c'est un
jouer un rôle majeur puisqu'il n'y a pas
de preuves qui ont été apportées 1
puisque les travaux scientifiques depuis
un an montrent que ça peut être naturel
quand on regarde le détail du virus on
ne voit pas quelque chose qui fait dire
non ça ça peut pas être ça peut pas être
naturel il ya eu des hypothèses comme ça
au début si on se rappelle certains ont
dit un peu des morceaux de sida dedans
et ça c'était les tories complètement
loufoque c'était donc ettori d'une fuite
de laboratoire loufoque mais il ya des
tories de file de laboratoire qui ne
sont pas loufoque
est ce que le virus il a existé de
telquel collectés dans la nature
et puis se seraient échappées voir est
ce qu'il ya eu des manipulations de
qu'on appelle de gains de fonction pour
le rendre plus dangereux puisque ça se
faisait aussi un vague donc tout ça fait
qu'on peut être soupçonneux de dogan au
début
mais simplement dans un deuxième temps
il n'y a pas eu de preuve devant la
chine a nié et et c'est très compliqué
de prouver que le virus est sorti de la
bouée n'est pas n'est pas naturel quant
à la partie propagande
ben évidemment ce qui a changé c'est le
président des états unis c'est ça qui
qui est très important quand on écoute
les médias aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que c'était interdit de dire que la
fuite du labo aurait été possible
c'était la position de donald trump
l'émission américaine pendant tout 2020
regardez le mois de mai il a expliqué
qu'ils avaient même les preuves que
c'était sorti du labo et dont j'avais
montré en en faisant un peu un discours
à la armes de destruction massive en
irak
le 15 janvier 2001 terrain ils ont de
nouveau dit la même chose donc c'était
trempe les médias n'ont pas suivi mais
par contre dès que biden est arrivé
l'administration n'a strictement pas
changé a toujours dit ben on sait pas si
c'est naturel et on sait pas si c'est
sorti dans la boue et c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas sûr à 100% un là les médias
ont tout de suite embrayé sur la
position américaine donc ce qui est très
amusant c'est que les médias d'habitude
suivent la propagande du gouvernement
américain de façon très très très
militaire presque mais là comme cette
épreuve
et comme il y avait eu des théories
vraiment absurde au début de complot de
swing du laboratoire un peu délirante
les médias n'avaient pas suivi donc
c'est très intéressant parce qu'on a un
jeu de propagande pour te propagande et
propagande anti chinoises contre bas ils
vont pas grande chinoise qui peut-être
mais peut-être ne m'ont pas on ne sait
pas quand il est très difficile d'y voir
clair
c'est vrai que là la théorie du
laboratoire a un peu changé au départ
dans nos souvenirs en tout cas j'ai
l'impression que ce que j'entends c'est
que c'est un virus qui auraient été
fabriqués dans un laboratoire en chine
mais de manière intentionnelle pour
éradiquer les beys l'humanité et dans le
souvenir aussi j'ai l'impression que
c'est au moment où disait bill gates
avait planifié tout ça mais pas
forcément parce qu'il ya eu des délires
un peu comme ça mais même luc montagnier
quand il sort sa théorie lui il suppose
que c'est un vaccin co qui travaillait
sur un vaccin contre le sida etc des
choses qui sont pas notamment totalement
loufoque parce que il ya eu des publi au
pouvoir des publications où on utilise
des coronavirus dans l'objectif de faire
un vaccin contre le sida et et lui donc
il disait que c'était l'idée de faire un
vaccin n'ont pas l'idée de faire une
bombe et il parlait aussi d'accidents et
après eu beaucoup d'autres gens qui me
disent c'est des chercheurs qui était
pas remarqué qu'ils disent est ce virus
il est bizarre parce que olivier dit
qu'il n'y a rien sur ce virus qui a pas
de preuves ya pas de preuve absolue mais
il ya quand même des éléments qui sont
un peu problématique
notamment des points très techniques
n'étaient pas rentrer là dessus mais qui
pourrait être une trace de laboratoire
est en tout cas qui corresponde
typiquement aux travaux que faisait le
laboratoire de one notamment en
collaboration aussi avec avec un
américain qui s'appelle rage barriques
et là aussi bon voilà on l'a vu la
semaine dernière dans les mails
d'anthony foot chic
anthony fochi voyez ça dès le mois de
janvier et il était un peu ennuyé de
voir que voilà en fait
wang travail avec les américains avec en
plus des fonds américains dont trump
disait oui c'est ça mais fochi aller
dans l'autre sens et les 30 bizet ça
aussi donc lié comme byden mémé trucks
et rome donc on ne suivait pas mais
baydan il c'est pas lui qui amène tous
que c'est vraiment les scientifiques les
découvertes qui le pousse en fait à
suivre le vent c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout byden qui change la donne
c'est rien ça c'est pas ben hayden et
c'est après le papier de cérium ce que
donne ce propos je mets même il a vu
parce qu'il ya des éléments les
américains un verre avec des dossiers
donc d'haydn je pense pas que ça soit la
propagande américaine qu'ils fassent ça
c'est plus vraiment ce revirement qui
part de trouvailles quad vraie
trouvaille massés durant ont fait un peu
trop mais maintenant ça que quand vous
et que vous dites si trump avait dit ça
ça aurait de ce fait scandale monsieur
verriez vous explique en fait qu'il
avait déjà dit donc le scandale il n'y
avait pas eu c'est qu'en fait quand
comme trame que 10 c'est nul quoi c'est
complotistes fait est que quand on me
parle on est plus prudent et je pense
qu'on a raison de l'être
on peut viser la chose et et là on est
on part sur cette hypothèse
on va passer une heure pour parler de
cette hypothèse on ne sait pas on n'a
pas la réponse que je vais pas venu vous
dire que j'ai la réponse je n'en sais
rien mais peut-être qu'il faut écouter
ce que disent les gens et s'accorder
fatus au fait que le temps de la science
et en dvd ce n'est pas le même il faut
un an deux ans trois ans pour qu on
retrace devient virus est ce qu'on a
dans son pendant dans sa séquence des
traces de manipulation on a un nez tueur
qui vous me dit que non bon bah moi je
suis pas spécialiste en génétique
je connais pas engagé mais pas génétique
s'est joint disent que non
peut-être qu'à des raisons si ces
publics dans la nature ça pourrait tout
ça qu'est ce qu'on a en face pour dire
que oui c'est un virus créé par l'homme
ou coupable si on fait la liste de
toutes les théories du complot on a là
des dizaines sur ce virus et donc la
course de dimanche
on est heureux d'écouter de complotisme
en mesure de les écouter quand on a eu
des dizaines le virus n'existe pas deux
il existe en fait il n'est pas dangereux
3 et d'exister mais c'est ça c'est les
vaccins qu'ils étaient dangereux ou même
c'est l'idée que craint virus existent
qui rend les dents malades venus des
dizaines de toits comme ça et les gens
étaient très très heureux de sauter sur
une hypothèse qui n'était pas celle
officielle pour plein de raisons parce
que les théories officielles parfois
sont arrangés et c'est bien vrai et au
final il faut être s'accorder sur le
fait qu' il faut attendre avant de dire
qu'on sait est-ce qu'il ya consensus
aujourd'hui sur le régime du virus non
est ce qu'il ya des bonnes raisons pour
dire que c'est une résine artificielle
non plus donc on fait est que l'umih
d'hypothèses des virus qui arrivent
spontanément un à plein dans l'histoire
on est plein donc moi je m'arrête là
après si vous voulez dire que vous savez
je vous disais que ces étapes de leur
mieux et si vous avez raison très bien
mais d'autres avant vous comme raul
qu'un virage qu'il aurait pu avoir
raison sur la chloroquine est ce que
nous ce que je dis dans le tabac cela
durant pour il se trouve que dans le
livre de de brice perrier indie
absolument pas que la théorie de
l'action de laboratoire et vérifiée et
prouvée est il dit simplement qu'il ya
des indices et que c'est à 17,10 tête
depuis le début et que il était étrange
on n'est pas voulu n'ai regardé et moi
le débat d'aujourd'hui je ne fais pas
sur le sur le fait qu' est-ce que cette
thèse est vrai parce que j'aurais pris
des démunis des immunologistes ou des
virologistes à votre place je le fais
sur comment tout à coup la même thèse
qui est fière été condamné à 6000
intérêts de la conspiration
toutacoo peuvent faire la une d'un
certain nombre de grands journaux qui il
ya encore très peu l'auraient
véritablement
abandonnés ou en tout cas écarté
d'emblée sans l'étudier parce qu'au fond
tous ces journalistes aujourd'hui ou
facebook ou joe biden je ne fonctionne
absolument pas sur des enquêtes
scientifiques dont ils se seraient tout
à coup emparé le seul qui a fait une
enquête à ma connaissance c'est vous
c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui on a le droit
d'évoquer cette piste on n'est pas
condamné pour l'avoir évoquée et
j'aimerais ça comprendre comment on
passe de la théorie de la conspiration
plausible à la vérité officielle en
attente
vous avez une réponse est jugée
excessive robert on peut formuler
certaines hypothèses qui sont que le
journalisme dominant a perdu une grande
partie de son autonomie professionnelle
qui consiste normalement à travailler
sans se demander si ça va alimenter la
thèse du complot ou au contraire si il
faut suivre les ordres donnés par le
gouvernement ou le courant dominant ou
ce que pense la majorité des gens qui
pensent bien ou mal etc on a la une un
miroir grossissant de cette perte de
cultures professionnelles qui
normalement implique que les
journalistes fassent des enquêtes
prennent du recul prennent du temps sans
se laisser dicter leur calendrier la une
de leurs journaux par par la peur de
déplaire à x ou de déplaire à y ou de
s'embarquer dans des thèses qui sont ou
non aux complotistes et on a depuis le
début de cette pandémie
un traitement qui
qui est souvent extrêmement
superficielle qui rebondit sur la
dernière anecdote et qui cherche le
spectaculaire dans la polémique dans les
polémiques qui a depuis le début sur le
traitement ou pas sûr sur didier rahout
sur l'origine du du gyrus
on favorise finalement des pugilats de
l'expression caricaturale de position
notamment les chaînes d'information en
continu qui doivent animer avec du bruit
avec du spectaculaire sans arrêt et tout
ça ne favorise pas l'idée bah tiens si
j'essayais de faire une enquête si je
m'interrogeais sur les logiques de
systèmes qui rendent ou non plausibles
le ce virus sont d'origine naturelle ou
pas et du et par conséquent on accroît
on accroît l'opacité on accroît le
complotisme parce que les gens ont perdu
confiance dans les médias et c'est ça
qui est extrêmement dangereux parce que
on n'arrive plus finalement avoir un
débat un peu sérieux sur quoi que ce
soit par peur de s'y perd de sa part
d'autres choses et c'est cette sérénité
qui vous retrouvez vous avez l'air
d'être d'accord tous les deux olivier
berruyer
oui je partage bien sûr c'est un total
hypothèse au début on aurait dû être
traité beaucoup plus en profondeur parce
qu'il ya plein d'éléments je rappelle
qu'ils pouvaient l'accréditer assez
fortement au pays afin d'en débattre et
fallait enquêter et les médias
absolument refuser de faire ça utilisant
leurs armes de de discréditation par
part soit disant complotisme les chasses
aux complotistes c'est quelque chose qui
peut vraiment empêché de connaître la
vérité parce que des fois il peut y
avoir des hypothèses
des hypothèses où il ya un complot mais
parce qu'en l'espèce s'il y a une fille
du labo il ya un complot chinois pour le
cacher tout le monde dit vous noté ce n
est pas qu on peut tisser un accident
bien sûr que l'accident ait pas pour un
petit gars ça fait un an que les chinois
dans ce cas-là mentir et donc il y aura
un complot chinois peut-être peut-être
pas c'est juste qu'on n'en sait rien et
ça m'est très compliquée puisqu'elle
prend demande des enquêtes mais qui va
enquêter
qui va aller enquêter parce qu'il n'ya
pas encore un pays mondiale qui peut
envoyer la police pour enquêter en chine
ya des états souverains
donc la chine on lui dit tiens à ce
qu'ils appellent fait des labos la chine
dit non après c'est compliqué leur dire
vous revenez d'autres enquêtes donc on
envoie un envoi le ms puisque c'est
l'organisation internationale de la
santé
ça revient en disant oui mais il y avait
des chinois donc tout ça c'est pas
fiable donc la question c'est quand est
ce que on sera fiable parce qu'ils ont
été ou est la pâté chinois si ils sont
innocents
elles disent on dit qu'on est innocent
on nous envoie le msl fait un rapport
disant qu'on est innocent ça va toujours
pas donc la question c'est est-ce que
c'est le département d'état américain
qui doit faire banquette pour dire à la
fin qu'on est coupable et c'est très
compliqué parce que on dit faut
peut-être plusieurs années pour
connaître oui et peut-être qu'on
connaîtra jamais parce que c'est assez
perverse ce questionnement si on y
réfléchit
si le virus était pas naturel si
nécessitait des manipulations bas ce
serait facile de dire c'est pas naturel
donc c'est fait en labo mais si c'est
naturel ça peut donc aussi avoir été
fort la boue puisque un labo on peut
copier ce que la nature a fait est là je
voyais un article qui a été très
partagés il ya une semaine très
intéressant de l'ancien journaliste du
new york times et à un moment donné et
glisse l'enquète de l' oms n'a pas été
satisfaisante parce que quand ils sont
revenus le gouvernement chinois n'a pas
pu leur apporter la preuve qu'ils
n'avaient pas manipuler le virus mais la
question c'est comment on fait pour
montrer qu'on n'a pas manipulé un virus
il ya pas de preuve de ça c'est très
compliqué il s'est déjà déjà le problème
c'est que les chinois n'ont pas donné
les données ils ont leurs banques de
données est fermée mise hors ligne
donc c'est quand même ça pose une vraie
question est donc ça déjà après il ya
aussi beaucoup de données comme pas été
donné par les chinois y compris des
données sur les sur les hommes parce que
y compris sur les animaux sur les toutes
les pistes en fait c'est que des données
qui sont arbitraires mais après je pense
qu'il faut bien voir que c'est pas du
tout moi j'affirme pas du tout que c'est
un virus qui en laboratoire le problème
c'est que c'est l'hypothèse qui a été
expliquée et là où leurs prénoms mais
aussi surtout sur la chine va ce cas ci
les lire à l einstein toute façon il
nous cache tout ne sera pas parce que
c'est les chinois mais ce qui peut ce
qu'on peut savoir c'est pourquoi le lan
cette publie ce papier qui discrédite ça
pourquoi nature fait un papier d'opinion
qui est ultra critiqué il ya des gens
qui écrivent et que tout le monde prend
pour argent comptant et c'est après
quand on gratte et ben on voit que celui
qui écrit barclays dans l'ue27 c'est un
collaborateur de du laboratoire de
chimie
c'est quand même c'est quelque chose que
vous écrire que vous raconter en détails
dans votre lit et qui serait quand même
très important qu'ils se retrouvent
experts de la tâche fort du 27 pour la
recherche de l'origine du virus avec le
prg et le présupposé de dire le
laboratoire c'est une théorie de complot
et qui se retrouvent experts de l'om est
ce le plus le plus actif là bas après
vous avez l'autre et qui exactement
alors c'est peter d'azac qui est
président d'une ong qui collectent des
virus et qui travaille à bah oui à
collecter des virus pour anticiper les
virus à venir et puis vous avez l'autre
qui s'appelle cristiano hendersen qui
lui travaille aussi avec la chine et qui
affiche en papier avec deux autres
personnes qui travaillent avec la chine
qui était primé est qui et qui le 31
janvier écrit à fochi on l'a vu cette
semaine que il se pose des questions
parce que le virus n'a pas l'air d'avoir
répondu à l'évolution naturelle et que
donc il pourrait avoir été en générer
quoi travaillent en laboratoire et qui
quinze jours après écrit un papier
disant hors de question c'est clairement
pas ça et le mot génial je les
interpeller sur twitter pour qu'il me
qu'est ce que c'était les nouveautés
parce que il dit oui
la séance a progressé c'est comme ça la
science mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu en
quinze jours la seule donnée nouvelle
qui a eu aucun jour c'est les virus de
pangolin qui sont presque tombés du ciel
de chine aussi avec un mec est qui qui a
fait le papier qui travaillait aussi
avec le henderson qui a fait ce papier
de nature et et donc il ya ces virus qui
arrive
et voilà on à la thèse du pangolin qui
arrivait alors qu'en fait ces virus de
pangolin sont foireux ils ont été même
reconnu nature a dit qu'il y avait un
problème avec ces virus ils sont ils
sont pas de bonne qualité et donc si le
seul truc qui fait passer de j'ai des
doutes assez impossible si les virus de
pangolin c'était un problème et c'est
que la science ne fonctionne pas
correctement et on aurait dû
s'interroger et et les scientifiques qui
s'interrogent ils sont censurés leurs
papiers page pas même quand ils amènent
des données très forte et et personne ne
relève ça avant avant que drastiques en
fait s'en occuper et d'eau et d'autres
quelques autres personnes et étienne
decroux lit et quelques autres on va
aimer monsieur durand moi je
et qui questionne bien la séance je
comprends pas pourquoi vous quand vous
voyez le papier du lendemain qui dit
penser que c'est une théorie du complot
que ce soit un virus travail en
laboratoire pourquoi vous prenez ça pour
argent comptant
vous quels cas pour questionner alors je
vous ai dit qu'est ce qu'on avait en
face comme article qui disait le
contraire quelques sérieux et clarté une
thèse en disant c'était du complot sais
c'est nul comme argument c'est pas un
argument et en plus si vous voyez que la
personne qui dit ça elle travaille que
le laboratoire douanes
c'est un problème qu'on a c'est un
problème d'accord mais très bien je n'ai
pas souvenir que j'utilisais crise 1 et
je n'avais pas de référence était un peu
ennuyeux d'accord c'est tant mieux
j'ai suivi un petit peu le la manière
dont la compresseur en parlait rigoler
et c'est là que je suis un descendant
pas ce qu'on me dit il fallait et
écouter ça peut-être que c'est vrai mais
je veux dire au final on aura tous raté
quelque chose et on va tous apprendre
des trucs au fur et à mesure
si certains au vu des détails que
d'autres n'ont pas vu et pas tant mieux
pour eux peut-être qu'avec de détail qui
est qui et qui est intéressant mais le
la prudence attentiste déjà à ne pas
prêter d'intention aux gens donc le le
complotisme c'est quoi ses dires il ya
un truc que je ne comprends pas j'ai pas
la réponse
je trouve quelqu'un a accusé est pas
c'est lui et ça c'est là c'est la
méthode à ne pas utiliser donc je me
nathalie de faire ça peut-être que quand
on est dans une crise mondiale avec une
pandémie
peut-être que je ne travaillais pas
aussi bien de manière aussi sereine
qu'en temps normal et certainement que
si et certainement que les pressions
pour que des choses se traitait plutôt
que d'autres évidemment dans les
compagnies est-ce que vous avez sans
doute je me rappelais dernière mais là
on est dans une instrumentalisation du
complotisme on n'est pas dans des ddc
studio qu'ils disent et comploté c'est
peter d'azac
penser ça c'est complotistes et il est
clair qu'une hypothèse tout à fait
envisageable
on l'a disqualifié sous ce prétexte de
complotiste et c'est ça qui est pas
normal je vous interromps tous les deux
ont fait une pause on repense débat
juste après ben cardin autour des crypto
actifs mais ces dernières semaines trou
de 4 le cours du bitcoin s'effondre elle
perd 30% de sa valeur en quelques mots
on peut difficilement pour l'instant
parler de crash vous avez quelque chose
est monté jusqu'à 60 mille euros et qui
est redescendu à 30 mais ça vaut encore
30 millions au plus un marché est petit
plus évidemment il est sujet à de la
volatilité
c'est la vie d'un actif comme comme
bitcoin que de subir ce genre de crash
on essaie de vendre ça comme quelque
chose de tout à fait tranquille et qui
ne peut que monter non ça à 200 bourses
hommes mais comme tout je rappelle que
dans le monde il ya presque un milliard
de personnes qui ont vu en 2020 leurs
monnaies nationales se déprécier de plus
de 20%
effectivement que c'est une ça peut être
une monnaie d'échangé pour ces gens là
donc la monnaie est ce qu'elle fait en
l'occurrence si les gens s'en servent
comme une monnaie il faudra l'accepter
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'imposant
l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
on repose débat avec brice perrier
l'auteur de sart skov 2 aux origines du
mal qui est paru chez belin avec olivier
berruyer du site les crises l'auteur de
les faits sont têtus aux éditions des
arènes et cécile robert l'auteur deux
dernières nouvelles du mensonge et
thomas c'est durant l'auteur de la
science des balivernes
je trouve ça inquiétant et pour moi
c'est ça le vrai sujet du débat de ce
soir
tout ça c'est inquiétant que des
professionnels de l'information valide
ou invalide une thèse pour des raisons
qui au fond sont des raisons de
politique c'est l'impression qu'on a
dans cette dans cette affaire d origine
de duke au vide c'est pas des raisons
scientifiques ils ont pas fait de
progrès en sciences ils n'ont pas fait
dans kate c'est pour des raisons
politiques qui sont liées à l'or au fait
que joe biden a dit qu'on ne pouvait au
fait que quelques
scientifiques ont écrit une lettre
ouverte qu'il est autorisé désormais de
citer nos fêtes c'est un phénomène
moutonnier comme l'était le fait de
rejeter la thèse jusqu'à présent olivier
berruyer sur ce sujet oui tout à fait
c'est ce qui est assez ce qui est assez
frappant dans cette dans cette histoire
là alors faut quand même aussi se
rappeler du contexte de l'époque qui
évacue est peut-être un peu trop vite
ces gens peut taper sur les médias tout
à l'heure mais il faut bien se rappeler
que dès fin janvier 2020 vous avez quand
même des théories qui explique que
[Musique]
le laboratoire du bn c'est en fait un
laboratoire d'armes de biologique que ça
a été fait par exprès par la chine avec
l'aide de bill gates et compagnie et
donc c'est aussi pour ça les
scientifiques ont réagi dans la fameuse
lettre du 27 dont parle brice 1
mais moi il me semble assez clairement
que dans cette lettre un ce qu'ils
évacuent c'est la théorie d'une chimère
c'est la théorie de je prends le virus
du sida et puis je bricole et puis ça
fait le strass etc etc toute façon des
scientifiques comme sade évacueront
jamais à 100% la possibilité que ça a
été fait un laboratoire puisque si c'est
naturel ça peut être fait en laboratoire
faut se rappeler qu'à ce moment là
d'ailleurs en france il ya une vidéo
d'un hurluberlu expliqué le virus a été
fait en france par l'institut pasteur
parce qu'il a trouvé un brevet sur
internet du sera sain et que cette vidéo
elle est vue par 3 millions de personnes
et que l'institut pasteur commence à se
faire agresser à des tags sur ses murs
son personnel se fait harceler et la
famille du personnel se fait harceler
parce qu'il travaille à l'institut
pasteur
l'institut pasteur est obligé de porter
plainte en diffamation contre lui c'est
la première fois que l'institut pasteur
porté plainte en diffamation
donc il ya quand même un phénomène à
l'époque qui existent et qui fait que
certains scientifiques ont réagi en
disant matin d arrêter de raconter
n'importe quoi quand on regarde ce virus
on voit qui peut être naturelle mais
évidemment comme je répète qu'on ya
plusieurs théories du labo qu'on essaie
de présenter comme une seule on se perd
un petit peu et ce pour quoi les
scientifiques vraiment se dresser
c'était cette idée de dire m'attendais
ciel cowitz airpost des scientifiques et
donc c'était aussi une démarche anti
science qui était fait réagir
malheureusement l'hypothèse de paris
avait une chauve souris vous avez déjà
des rues sans la bossa s'est échappée
voir est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas un peu
bricolé parce qu'il le faisait aussi
c'était une théorie qui aurait dû être
discutée beaucoup plus mais pour des
raisons en particulier politique parce
que parce que trump le disait ça a été
évacué et mais c'est ça qui est très
intéressant quand même c'est cet
affrontement où les médias ont fait un
virage à 180 degrés alors qu'en fait il
n'y a pas grand chose et qui est apparu
depuis lors il est apparu un petit truc
il ya il ya une dizaine de jours un
article du wall street journal qui
explique qu' il y aurait eu trois
scientifiques du labo un des urnes qui
aurait été malade
un mois avant le début de l'épidémie et
de chose qui ressemble soi ou qu'ovide
soient à bas une grippe normale
est ce qui est très très amusant dans
cette histoire c'est que ça a relancé
aux états unis très fortement cette
hypothèse
et vous avez tous les deux jours sur
avatar d ça se renforce ya quelque chose
il faut creuser quand on regarde tout ça
est issue d'un rapport confidentiel des
renseignements américains c'est les
mêmes qui ont fait comme les arbres
géants et cif en irak
donc c'est fiabilité pour savoir si un
type solide en lui un rhume soit ils ont
peut-être le président n'en sais rien 1
et mais alors c'est là où c'est à peine
croyable quand on regarde et personne ne
l'a souligné le journaliste qui fait ça
dans votre journal c'est michael gordon
et c'est le journaliste qui a sorti les
arbres qu'est-ce que sur maxime en irak
dans new york times en 2002 et l'article
avait été retiré en tout cas elle très
fortement critiqué pour les matériaux
lui-même de deux ans après donc on voit
que c'est toujours évidemment les
services de renseignements américains le
pentagone qui sort ce genre
d'information c'est peut-être vrai un
septet faux seins en tout cas c'est de
la propagande par hypothèse est par
définition de ce qu'est la propagande
anti ch l'avait déjà dit c'était dans la
lettre qu'ils avaient avant que trump
art dans la lettre du département d'état
il parlait déjà de ces scientifiques
balade est donc en fait c'est pas du
tout un scoop c'est juste un truc affûté
avec un peu plus de détails mais pas
beaucoup plus
et pour préciser la cité pasteur avait
quand même eu dvd des problèmes
précédemment du temps de pasteur où on
accusait pasteur quand même de fabriquer
des vaccins pour les vendre très cher
donc les anti vaccins existait déjà du
temps de vagues de pasteur et l'institut
pasteur était soupçonnée d'aider pires
des pires travers mais il ya ce
processus de rectification il existe
actuellement dans nos journaux français
si vous allez sur le site d'un croc
quotidien du soir on vous explique que l
article qui est toujours là on l'a écrit
à l'époque avec ce qu'on savait à
l'époque
en fait on n'en sait pas plus que vous
l'avez dit mais on a changé simplement
d'options et que ce qui était considéré
comme une obsession nauséabonde de la
part des français qui continuent à se
demander en majorité s'il n'y avait pas
eu un accident de laboratoire
tout à coup c'est considéré comme
quelque chose de tout à fait naturel et
normal qu'on se pose cette question là
et ça c'est pas vrai parce que vous
parlez de cet article des décodeurs du
monde qui est sur l'étrange obsessions
d'un quart des français et on dit
c'était ce qu'on savait à l'époque mais
c'est pas du tout vrai ce qu'on savait à
l'époque parce que 10 c'est pas possible
déjà il ya un côté un peu de prendre les
gens qui disent ça pour des demeurés
pour des gens qui sont des analphabètes
de la science et c'est ce qui est écrit
dans le papier ces érudits les stades de
conspiration voile ski mais ça et après
vous avez un expert qui vient vous dire
c'est impossible de fermer des travaux
en laboratoire sur un virus sans que ça
se voit et voilà et n importe qui le
cernent étudiants de première année il
le verrait si les travaux et donc ça
c'était pas il n'y a pas une découverte
dans l'année que l'on pouvait le faire
mais moi cette personne je l'appelle
huit mois après et il me dit bah oui
bien sûr qu'on peut le faire mais à quoi
ça sert de le dire ça sert à quoi de
dire le contraire c'est pas c'est pas
bon quoi et là il n'y a pas eu de
nouvelles données a juste eu un discours
qui veut être donnée qui fait dire
quelque chose
un chercheur qui est faux en fait est
qu'ils étaient fous ya un an comme il
sait faut aujourd'hui anne cécile robert
il faudrait retrouver on parlait d'un
grand quotidien du soir
la formule d'hubert beuve méry le
fondateur du monde qui disait le
journaliste fait une question de
distance distance par rapport aux faits
distance par rapport au pouvoir
distance par rapport à soi même et à ses
propres préjugés et c'est une bonne
formule qui permet de suivre les
événements sont se laisser dicter encore
une fois ce qu'on écrit ce qu'on dit ce
par les préoccupations et les priorités
des pouvoirs des laboratoires des
présidents de ceux qui ne sont pas ok
voudrait l'être
et là les erreurs commises par un
certain journalisme dans cette période
viennent en grande partie de cette perte
de distance les faits qu'on a besoin de
suivre des des mots d'ordre qu'on a
besoin aussi d'alimenter la machine de
l'information en continu et on perd on
perd la distance critique et par
ailleurs on oublie qu'en tant que
journaliste on n'est pas obligé d'avoir
un avis sur tout je veux dire on n'est
pas on est des journalistes on n'est pas
forcément des spécialistes ou des
scientifiques
notre premier devoir c'est d'abord
d'exposer la réalité de la manière la
plus honnête possible en allant chercher
les faits en les mettant à l'épreuve en
essayant de mesurer les thèses
contradictoires et rien que ça c'est
l'essentiel on n'est pas forcément
obligé de fournir la conclusion dire ça
vient de là ça vient de là on n'est pas
forcément en situation de le faire là où
on pèche c'est quand on ne fait pas le
travail de mise à distance et de
recherche d'éléments danalyse et des
éléments de cause comme comme vous le
savez je travaille au monde diplomatique
donc on a la chance nous d'être un
mensuel
donc depuis le début de la pandémie on a
pu c'est à dire déterminer notre propre
calendrier et on a fait ce qu'on estime
intéressant de faire en tant que
journaliste c'est à dire des papiers qui
analyse les mécanismes comment
fonctionne l'économie mondiale
comment fonctionne le commerce mondial
et le rôle des laboratoires les conflits
d'intérêts qui font que ce type de
problème et peut et possible parce que
sinon si on reste sur le le nez collé
sur la vitre de l'événement eh bien on
va passer du sart ce que v2 au prochain
puisqu'il y en a
annonce déjà d'autres et on n'aura rien
appris aux citoyens si on a en fait
contenté de courir après les événements
et si on n'a pas analysé la mécanique
des choses qui rendent finalement nos
sociétés dangereuse et qui rendent
possible finalement dé la propagation de
temps démis telle que celle qu'on vit
depuis un an et qui paralyse tout ben
c'est durant on parle beaucoup des biais
cognitif qui nous inclinent à croire à
des théories fumeuses
est ce que on ne néglige pas les biais
cognitif qui nous oblige aussi ont
réfuté un certain nombre parce qu'on a
peur que ce soit nous plonger tout à
coup dans le mauvais camp mais ya pas de
quand ça le truc c'est que on a tous
envie de croire des choses vraies des
choses fausses et les vrais complots et
10 est le pire ennemi de l' enquête
sérieuse de complot
c'est la pensée conspirationnistes parce
que on n'a jamais découvert un complot
parce que quelqu'un a dit oh mon dieu
quelqu'un at elle intérêt je suis sûr
que c'est lui dont on a l'une des
preuves ont fait des recherches
on prend du temps on questionne c'est un
travail de vandalisme le confédéralisme
ça existe aussi on a des gens qui
aujourd'hui j'en ai plein mon tuteur qui
disent vous êtes trop nu vous êtes en
pls parce qu'on avait raison
on le savait et quand on demande quoi
avait dégradé les les faux que félix les
mails de défaut de chiffres
voilà c'est la preuve qu'un scandale
enron demande pourquoi qu'est ce que
d'en bas il dit allez regardez vous même
et les gens en fait sont tellement sûr
que quand quelqu'un leur dis qu'il ya un
scandale parce que les démêle ont fui en
futaie il cherchait pas à les vérifier
quoi ils sont sales et rassure ça leur
fait plaisir c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
eu raison et en gros à des gens qui sont
devant leur télé comme devant de télé
réalité qu'on 10e ou devant le clodia je
pense que c'est c'est lui quelques de
décrire le noir ils n'ont aucune idée qu
à la fin quand le film avance des
hypothèses avancées à super contente
d'avoir dit que c'était lui parce que là
on croirait que c'est lui et voilà et
donc c'est des gens qui sont très passif
équipe a une position étonnante comme ça
de manière par rapport à leur ressenti
par rapport à leurs billets et on est
tous visés et donc moi le premier faire
attention mais en fait un juge bien trop
vite
les gens sont très prompts à prendre
position pour ou contre ceux ci et après
sans se rendre compte
ils s'engagent eux mêmes et ils
s'empêche de penser contre eux mêmes
pour peut-être aller parce que vous
pourrez lire
donc il nous faut des enquêteurs si
monsieur même peut l'espérer a raison
c'est très important qu'il puisse te
dire je suis content que ça se passe
mais il faudra un peu caricaturé les les
positions des uns et des autres on a
tous intérêt à découvrir la vérité donc
il ya des exceptions il ya des gens qui
vont y perdre mais là on a tous intérêt
à ce que la vérité éclate
évitant de prendre ceux qui pensent
différemment pour des idiots là vous
dites les gens dans leur canapé
ils se font des idées il aime bien avoir
c'est sûr mais je pense que la latitude
qui fait qu' on reprend une autre forme
d'outrance sauf que cette outrance elle
est avec des gens qui sont pas dans leur
canapé mais des gens qui sont des
décideurs les gens qui portent la parole
et et qui vont exclure des hypothèses
tout à fait légitime et amon et c'est ça
qui fait le complotistes c'est ça qui
alimente davantage de complotiste que le
mec dans son canapé qu'un peu
d'influencé alors que quand vous avez
des personnes qui aurait autorité qui ni
des choses évidentes et qui propage des
mensonges en fait là vous allez avoir
les complotistes il va dire à bâle et il
m'a menti là dessus donc il va me mentir
sur autre chose et il ya peut-être une
fuite de laboratoire mais alors pourquoi
il y aurait pas bill gates avec les
quais complice avec les chinois pour
empoisonner la planète entière
et si on n'est pas plus rigoureux sur la
façon de discréditer des hypothèses qui
sont qui type sont tout à fait légitimes
sous le couvert de complotisme on incite
aux complotistes mais c'est là où c'est
beaucoup de gens qui luttent contre le
complotisme en fait le favori ce parce
que ils vont écarter des choses des
victimes en mettant tout le monde dans
le même panier
est ce qu'il faut faire c'est faire un
peu le tricot en fait je suis d'accord
c'est la thèse de votre livre anne
cécile oui je vous donnerai la parole
après tabasser durant l été n 1 vous
pour dire que le mot con petit utilisé
pour discréditer les autres c'est vrai
de tous les pouvoirs
vous allez dans n'importe quel pays on
va dire les opposants sont des
conspirationnistes évidemment
mais de la même manière que raciste est
devenue une injure ça ne veut pas dire
que le racisme n'existe pas ou que c'est
acceptable ou sajoo d'aucun problème
non mais je dirais qu'en mai comme ça
les choses sont dites ça me paraît plus
clair mc fils durant j'ai l'impression
que je viens d'y à brice perrier c'est
la thèse de votre livre dernières
nouvelles du mensonge c'est qu'en fait
le peu le conspirationnisme aînés delà
de la prolifération de ce que vous
appelez les vérités officielles qui dans
les années 80 90 ont commencé empoisonné
la parole publique
donc c'est un cessez-le robert de niro
c'est merveilleux les merveilles du
direct ya une sorte de jeu de miroirs
pathologique de nos sociétés entre le
complotisme et les vérités officielles
puisque on paye aussi le discrédit d'un
certain du système médiatique dominant
qui depuis des décennies a validé toutes
sortes de mensonges qui était à l'époque
des vérités officielles les armes de
destruction massive
le plan fer à cheval de de milosevic
récemment aux états unis
la thèse de donald trump et tente un de
poutine est quasiment agents de poutine
qui a volé en éclats après le rapport
muller dhr donc personne
ne parle et tout ça effectivement
affaibli les médias et en réintroduisant
une monstruosité dans la vie
démocratique et là la vérité officielle
celle contre laquelle on ne peut pas
aller et en retour on a une autre
pathologie qui est le complotisme qui
consiste à avoir des complots partout
mais c'est aussi une défaite de la
pensée et qui traduit que le fait que
nos sociétés deviennent de plus en plus
fermé et j'allais me dire restent
réfractaires au débat public
réfractaire à l' échange libre et
raisonnée qui permet de faire advenir la
vérité pour ça que j'ai un peu de mal à
rentrer dans la polémique sur sur ce
virus parce que je pense que c'est un
peu un épiphénomène par rapport à des
sujets beaucoup plus graves qui tiennent
à la manière dont on construit le débat
public et dont sur le long terme
on va redonner de la crédibilité aux
urnes ou redonner confiance aux citoyens
dans la vie publique et pour ça
si on veut arriver à ça faut qu'on
retrouve un peu de sérénité un peu de
calme la gestion du temps et puis ne pas
essayer d'avoir toujours raison sur
l'autre en lui imposant nos propres
pensées admettre la discussion peut être
qu'on a raison à certains moments tort à
d'autres l'essentiel c'est de contribuer
à donner de la substance au débat pour
que la démocratie puisse fonctionner
qu'au bout du compte les citoyens
puissent trancher une vieille et
rouillée
j'ai publié sur les crises aujourd'hui
un article très intéressante de la
semaine dernière de christian d'austen
qui est un des cinq plus grands
virologues spécialiste du président de
la planète alors il parle un peu
l'hypothèse du labo dit quelque chose de
très intéressant un moment puisqu'il
anime une podcast très célèbre en
allemagne où les gens vont repenser
informés et toutes les semaines il
explique ou en hébreu née l'épidémie il
dit mais à un moment donné je me suis
rendu compte de quelque chose à ces
problématiques et en particulier dans
les médias c'est que la science
normalement ça marche un peu par
consensus autrement dit la société
confie à des gens spécialisés 1 qui vont
passer dix ans quinze ans de leur vie
sur 1 sur 1 sur un sujet très pointu
et puis les gens vont discuter puis un
jour où 90% des gens vont être d'accord
et puis ce sera peut pas de consensus
scientifique et la vérité scientifique
entre guillemets du moment présent
qui pourra changer simplement dans les
médias comme est toujours 10 % des gens
voient qu'ils sont pas d'accord avec le
consensus et c'est très bien c'est ce
qui fait éventuellement avancer la
science dans les médias ont tendance à
inviter une personne qui représente les
90% une personne qui représente les 10
et puis ça fait un petit débat et puis
les gens qui écoutent pas ils peuvent
pas trop comprendre qui a raison qui a
tort
et au final ils finissent par avoir un
raisonnement qui compte c'est celle du
web j'aime bien ce que raconte lui donc
c'est lui qui doit avoir raison et ça je
pense que c'est par rapport à la point
que vous sous l'évier tout à l'heure par
rapport aux journalistes s'assigne pour
moi une perte vraiment compétences
scientifiques des journalistes bien qu
on est passé d'un journalisme où on est
compétent l'essai de comprendre en fils
travaille qu'à fébrile sur ses
formidables qui l'a fait brice bravo
votre libre peut ne pas être d'accord
quelques petits d'interprétation mais
quel travail oit ou super devrait passer
un temps colossal aujourd'hui un
journaliste un bon quand il passe une
demi journée sur l'article c'est bon
maximum qu'on va lui donner
donc il n'y a pas de compétence n'est
pas de compétences qu'on va faire du
débat parce qu'au moins besoin d'être
compétent on va laisser les gens parler
et donc on voit que malheureusement du
coup comme on est dans ce manque de
compétence la science a tendance à se
politiser dans les analyses des
journalistes dans le journal ici les
deux mois sont moins compétents de plus
en plus militants et ça ça veut dire
quoi circulation se politise donc il
commence à y voir une science entre
guillemets de droite et une séance entre
guillemets de bosch et quand vous lisez
les médias aux états unis un
conservateur et des médias entre les
progressistes
vous savez vous apercevez vous compensez
avoir une vision de la science très
différentes
évidemment sur ce sujet mais évidemment
aussi sûr j'ai pas tel bide il
s'aguerrit du coc vide où certaines le
sujet donc on voit qu'on est en train de
perdre 1 et souffre très grave puisque
la science est quelque chose qui est
censé nous rapprocher veut dire environ
peut laisser des spécialistes à discuter
de voir ce qu'il en est bien moi je m'en
fous quelques questions naturelles où
que ce soit dans la bo bomba très bien
quand je vois pas trop ce que ça va
changer au final mais bon on va laisser
des scientifiques décidé mais on voit
que maintenant c'est devenu un enjeu
politique
vous avez tout d'un coup bah voilà tous
les médias conservateurs que les peines
et les salles d'aude chinois et puis
attention c'est pas juste un débat comme
ça entre amis et des sénateurs
américains commencent à dire il ne faut
pas rembourser les milliards qu'on doit
la chine parce qu'elle ment parce qu'il
est responsable de la crise
qu'elle a fait le virus un dogue il ya
des gros enjeux derrière et tous les
gens qui sont en train de peut-être de
trop s'avancer sur ce sujet là sont en
train de faire quand même le jeu de la
propagande américaine et la propagande
de l'otan info quand même bien devoir
légal très intéressant ce qui se passe
ce qui est pas dire qu'il faut être non
plus naïfs sur ce que font les chinois
mais donc il faut être prudent il faut
voir des journalistes et pas que me
disait très bien madame robert inquiets
qui font leur métier qui prennent de la
distance et ça malheureusement le modèle
économique aujourd'hui des médias ne
permet plus ça et c'est pour ça qu'on a
de plus en plus de problèmes c'est pour
ça que les gens sont plus en plus
divisés sur des sujets qui sont plus des
opinions comporte des opinions
différentes mais sur un sujet aussi
fondamental et qui est censé nous
rapprocher de la science et on peut dire
que le débat sur les autres les pros et
les antis raout s'apparente à ce que
vous venez de raconter olivier berruyer
oui par exemple il ya comme une vérité
scientifique est apparu mais certains
refusent et ça je le dirai c'est un
temps que c'est un problème dans la
société mais je trouve que ça en dit
long sur la décadence d'une société a
quand même la science 1 commence à ne
plus fonctionner correctement
on voit que c'est pas juste des
personnes là attention ça veut dire que
les autorités n'agissent pas le csa n'a
pas agi à la une et seb n'a pas gilles
ministère n'a pas agi enfin en tout cas
la faillite des institutions justice n'a
pas agi on l'a vu encore un mois me
semble enfin vraiment me fait me fait me
fait peur et un dernier mot sur cette
histoire de complotiste que j'aime
vraiment pas ce mot là pour les raisons
qu'a très bien évoqué brise tout à
l'heure je n'aime pas l'idée qu'il ya
des gens qui seraient des complotistes
il peut y avoir des hypothèses
complotistes certaines sont complètement
farfelus et d'autres peuvent être
raisonnable parce que des fois il ya des
complots comme l'a dit monsieur durand
donc il faut les analyser mais j'aime
vraiment pas cette qualification de
personnes qui seraient complotistes
comme si c'était un virus vous l'avez
achoppé et puis vous êtes d'un côté vous
êtes d'un côté désolé vous êtes perdus
l'hôpital psychiatrique c'est bientôt
pour vous et ça c'était comme ce qu'ils
découlaient de l'article ac a cité un
monsieur monsieur perrier tout à l'heure
un dans le journal du soir c'était
vraiment dégueulasse cet article là sur
les gens qui émettait des doutes et dont
on voit très bien qu'ils étaient pour
certains parfaitement raisonnable mais
quand on qualifie ces personnes là pour
les disqualifier ans parce que c'est
depuis 2007 que ça existe c'est comment
j'évite de débattre je veux dire que le
gars les complotistes et puis puis donc
on fait des conneries comme vous comme
vous suit
même pas étudié cette hypothèse là qui
peut être étaient été était raisonnable
est bon pour une espèce de mépris de
classe aussi c'est les élites qui disent
non attendez c'est le populo
complotistes machin alors que comme l'a
très bien dit aussi madame robert ford
et si vous regardez cette hypothèse
complotistes mais y'en a qui vont
parfaitement aux plaire aux élites 1
le rapport d'hier où le brésil c'est la
faute de la propagande de chez pas quels
pays
voyez ce que je veux dire donc un moment
donné ces théories du complot quand
vraiment elles viennent conforter vos
opinions 90% des gens seront prêts à y
adhérer assez facilement espériez oui
après c'est comme quand je pense que
cette histoire c'est quand même assez
révélateur en fait parce que bon on sera
peut-être pas qu'elle est là le fond des
choses parce qu'on aura peut-être pas
accès à tout bon il ya des éléments qui
feront peut-être que me sens avoir
l'accès à la chine on pourra trouver
mais moi je pense que c'est révélateur
de l'information comment elles passent
et notamment de l'information
scientifique à haut niveau et ça j'ai
l'impression que c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
tellement envie de voir parce
qu'aujourd'hui on dit bah oui mais
finalement c'était possible et puis
ouais parce que c'est les chinois qui
nous cachent donc c'est la faute à la
chine et l'américain est politiquement
vont faire comme ça mais les
scientifiques qui qui font les êtres qui
ont poussé à sa eu
ils ont rien contre la chine a dit ce
pacte est par contre ils disent que
c'est ce virus cette histoire ça pose
des questions sur la loggia la
publication scientifique le mode de
publication avec des avec une chance sur
avec des papiers qui sont faut qu'ils
passent dans des très grandes revues
nature a été très impliqué dans cette
histoire avec un truc qui relève plus de
la propagande que de la science et c'est
relayé et donc ça ça devrait nous
interroger et je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'on peut en plus nous
occidentaux
on peut se poser des questions là-dessus
et peut-être que c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
envie de moi j'avais la première
roquette du monde note et respect aucun
journal quasiment vote n'a été recensé
par quasiment aucun journal journaux
effet sur europe 1 et sur rt mais c'est
pas prises à temps
une de marianne donc il doit être un
petit peu connu avait les bonnes soldes
depuis un papier dans charlie hebdo en
un mois c'est quand même un peu étonnant
parce que je me disais je n'arrive ce
livre en plus c'est un contexte
incroyable jamais je n'aurais imaginé
quand j'ai commencé à écrire que le rsa
yade qui était là dedans bas il donne
alors tout le tout ce que vous avez
montré est théoriquement c'était le
tapis rouge et bah non personne ne sait
encore puisqu'ils sont pas sur ces
réseaux reparler apparemment dernier mot
et thomas c'est durant quelques minutes
ou pas comme motif le compo tisme ça va
être de croire qu'on a compris quelque
chose avant d'avoir les preuves c'est
croire qu'on peut dénoncer des des
coupables et connaître les intentions
des gens on n'a pas accès à la tête est
ce que j'ai une tête des gens donc il
faut enquêter livre il faut travailler
avant de dire qu'on sait et quand on
fait pas le travail
alors on n'est qu'au petit et c'est pas
je fais d'accord pour dire que le mot il
faut l'utiliser c'est pas infamant on
peut en sortir du groupe matis on peut
être acquise pour un sujet et publics
pour les autres mais dire qu'il faut pas
utiliser le mot qu'est ce qu'on fait
après que comment on qualifie les choses
ça me va compliquer le complotisme il
existe par rapport aux copines c'est
tellement grave comme sujet qu'il y en a
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
prudent
anne-cécile il faut retrouver de du
calme de la sérénité de la distance pour
qu'on s'y retrouve hélas la science
l'information médicale vont devenir des
éléments très importants du débat public
et le devoir des journalistes devoir de
la presse est contribuer à éclairer les
choses sans forcément vouloir toujours
avoir raison sur tout ou prendre partie
dans des dans des polémiques ils sont
pas forcément de de leur parti de leur
secteur joe bercy tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]